MALE SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
We've had a little bit
of a snafu with
our live stream today.
So if you just go to this link
up here, or click the link
inside this pre-recorded thing
here, you'll see the actual
video of Jake Archibald and Addy
Osmani talking about Dev
Tools in relation to
Chrome or mobile.
If you're watching this live
now, I'm sorry for actually
the mistakes that we've made.
Sounded really bad, actually.
It's basically we pre-recorded
the show.
And the actual quality of the
show when we broadcast it live
wasn't great.
And we want you to have the
best quality possible.
So go and look at this link.
And you'll be able to see
everything that happens and
that we talked about
around Dev Tools.
See you soon.
Bye bye.